Salut les Mentalos !
Souvent dans les commentaire je vous lis et puis vous mettez :
"Mèèèh comment tu fais qu'est-ce que tu vois quand la personne dit stop ?" etc.
Malgré toutes les explications c'est vrai que j'utilise plein de choses différentes pour essayer de voir quelque chose sur le visage
Et dimanche dernier y a Julien De Ruyck qui est venu à la maison,
On a fait une vidéo ensemble sur le développement personnel, j'en ai profité pour le filmer de très très près …
En lui demandant de penser à une lettre
Dans quelques instants je vais vous mettre la vidéo pour que vous puissiez essayer de trouver à quelle lettre il pense
Bah dans quelques instants d'ailleurs, c'est maintenant, donc regardez
On a rien prévu, on est bien d'accord ?
— Oui
— Je peux pas savoir ce que tu décides
Tu penses à une lettre, je peux pas la connaître
À partir de maintenant tu regardes toujours ici et tu penses à ta lettre, tout le temps
La seule chose que je te demande, c'est que, vraiment, quand je vais dire ta lettre, tu cries stop dans ta tête, réellement
Stop réellement
Comme s'il y avait une urgence, ok ?
Donc tu me regardes bien comme si tu me regardais dans les yeux, mais ça c'est mon œuil
Donc ta lettre ça peut être
Je vais m'arrêter là, pour moi je l'ai passée
C'était juste ou pas ?
(sinon je continue)
Oui oui, c'est juste
Donc on refait
Pareil quand tu entends ta lettre, tu cries stop dans ta tête, sauf que …
Tu vas pas imaginer un danger, en même temps je vais te demander d'imaginer un paysage un peu idyllique
Donc ça peut être une plage où t'as été en vacances, quelque chose comme ça
Mais en criant stop quand même
Ces deux choses en même temps, ça marche ?
C'est parti
Toujours le même exercice
Ok, on est sur G ?
Oui
Sur la lettre G ? Merci, c'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin
Alors je sais pas si vous aviez trouver que c'était la lettre G
Mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est que maintenant on a le support pour détailler
Et que je puisse vous expliquer, image à l'appui ce qui s'est passé
Contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait penser c'est rarement à l'évocation
de la lettre ou de la pensée précise de la personne qu'il se passe quelque chose
Mais juste avant, en anticipation, puisque la personne est en attente, ça crée un certain stress personnel
et tout le visage va commencer à communiquer juste avant
Et je trouve qu'on le voit très clairement ici quand je dis "F"
On a tous les muscles qui se préparent à avoir une réaction
Et après G, à partir de H, tout le visage commence à se détendre un petit peu puisque le job est fait
c'est passé, il se concentre juste à ne plus donner d'émotion
Au deuxième coup j'ai rajouté une visualisation exprès pour vous faire un autre exemple
Avec toujours le "Stop" de crier dans sa tête
On voit le même réflexe au niveau de la lettre F
Et en plus on voit les yeux légèrement se contracter
Alors, la pupille ne se bouge pas parce qu'il a la lumière directement dans le visage donc ça ne change rien
Mais néanmoins les paupières se contractent un petit peu, comme s'il y avait plus de soleil que la normale
C'est très léger, repassez la vidéo plein de fois pour le voir, et ça c'est un autre indice
Et pourquoi je lui ai fait faire une troisième fois ?
C'est pas parce que j'avais pas la lettre, je l'avais depuis le départ la lettre
C'est pour que vous puissiez voir trois fois d'affilée qu'on a la même réaction au même endroit, ce n'est pas un hasard !
Essayez de le faire sur quelqu'un mais prenez un choix plus restreint que le 26 lettres de l'alphabet
Pour commencer, vous pouvez par exemple lui demander de penser à un nombre entre 1 et 10
L'essentiel c'est que la personne joue le jeu avec vous, si elle ne veut pas jouer le jeu mentalement,
forcément, ça ne fonctionnera pas
Aujourd'hui sur Facebook sur la fan page je vous ai posé une question pour faire une vidéo ensemble
un truc participatif, ce qui va nous permettre de reparler du mind map ensemble
Si vous connaissez pas les mind maps, je vous mets un lien dans le descriptif de la vidéo,
comme d'habitude, je mets PLEEIIN de trucs dans le descriptif
L'idée c'est que vous me postiez dans les commentaires un mind map à vous, que vous faites
sur le sujet que vous voulez : un projet, quelque chose à apprendre, ce que vous voulez
Et après je vais faire une vidéo avec vos mind maps, et on va parler de la manière dont vous les avez réalisés, ce qui pourrait être amélioré
et peut-être que ça va servir aussi à la communauté selon le mind map que vous aurez fait
"Et c'est quoi ton Facebook ?"
C'est dans le descriptif !
Et abonnez-vous à sa chaîne là, à lui, vous cliquez sur sa petite tête
J'espère vraiment que cette vidéo vous aura plus et qu'elle vous sera utile
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir puisque le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, donc rendez-vous demain, 17h, ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes, c'est la date la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir sinon y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site :)